you said before that you were
heartbroken that uh that you didn't
take a [ __ ] in uh
the last two
i've taken
shits and everything i've taken
three shifts and three number one movies
i think that i blew my line i've i've
taken two i'm blowing it i hope i don't
do this on stage ah okay i've taken
three number twos and three number one
movies okay so uh to have this next
movie where i just didn't do it at all i
mean i had that toilet geyser thing and
i was trying every time but man with
that thing flying up there it was hard
how gnarly was that
i had black and blue thighs
you know behind my thighs but um it's
pretty intense like yeah and like you
really had to protect your junk because
it was just like that right
you sit on a clear plexiglas thing and
that thing just just kicked so hard
it was pneumatic pressure it wasn't the
water so much they had like air pressure
and tremaine just kept saying up it up
the pressure up the pressure but by the
end you know it's blowing me sky high so
you were sitting on a like a plexiglass
seat yeah it's clear and so like it was
actually uh like uh yeah so the water
wasn't hitting me it was actually uh
hitting a
water and the air would just
force up against this plate that would
that was on a small chain so it wouldn't
follow me up also so you know they were
afraid it would follow me up and then
hit me on the deck really heavy or hit
someone else in there and it looks so
good thanks but yeah we we practiced it
uh one day for i don't know maybe 10
times and got it dialed then on the day
i think we did it eight times wow
yeah the reactions were so great you
know like for for what i was saying i
was sounding critical of of the movie
let's also be clear that it was a
critical darling isn't that crazy like i
know what yeah i know at first i'm like
what's a critical darling yeah
though they loved it and they never
loved our other movies at all
he's got [ __ ] on [ __ ]
rotten whatever and we just took that in
our stride we were like well yeah of
course the greats don't love it this
time around like 87
fresh
i know i caught the world needed
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude